coming back to our triangle because
that's how we're talking about this you
got your own you're you're a villain
here we've called that theta right and
then the thing we introduced the big
thing was we we named all of these sides
in relation to theta right so the first
most important side is the longest one
the one opposite the right angle which
is the hypotenuse and you remember that
went from Pythagoras also a great guy
okay then you've got these other two
sides this ones next to or adjacent to
our angle okay and then this one was was
facing the other way okay so he's
opposite
okay now because you've just dropped
this off I'm going to use this
opportunity to to tell you something a
bit new from your say that we didn't
mention we sort of alluded to it better
nor even we use these three names of
signs to talk about particular ratios
right that we called them sine cos and
tan right sine cosine tangent okay we
said they always attach to an angle
right that's right okay now sohcahtoa
I'll write that down again is our the
body device for remembering which sides
are in the ratios that matter so for
instance sine goes with Oh an H so it's
or over H that's opposite online
pointless so we wrote down this right
opposite on hypotenuse by the same kind
of technique we've got cause which is
adjacent okay and then our last song Toa
that's opposite what a day sir
so this is just bring us back up to
speed from yesterday here's a new thing
for you okay I'll get a new color out in
fact how I look at our triangle oh we've
just startled man here Michael this
now this triangle because it's
right-angled and you've got this song
it's need up okay
theta might be 10 or might be 20 or 30
who knows what it is but I'm just
calling a theta bit like algebra you
know we just put in pretty rules letters
to talk about numbers what we don't know
what they are now we know that the
angles sort of every triangle even if
it's not right angle right the end was
on every trailer is 180 years so the
other question I should have poster you
very quickly is well this was 90 this
one's feet up whatever that is what was
this one over there bit but what I
haven't named yet okay now because we
know what they're all supposed to add up
to okay let me just put a question mark
there first okay if I add all of these
up I should get 180 right so let's just
see what happens I've got whatever that
ankle is all right I'll add it to feet
up and I'll add it to the right angle
which is 90 degrees and they should all
add up to 180 because the end result
right okay
yep
now they may be the same but what this
is Sarah that's right you know if this
one was not 45 this would be something
else we'll look at that 45 one a bit
later on that's important but only works
sometimes now I'm trying to work out
what this question mark is right that's
what I'm after
okay so I can rearrange this yeah
how are you guys I can take 90 degrees
away from both sides I could do that so
I have sorry
whatever that angle is plus P dog and
you're going to be left with on the rank
inside 90 degrees okay the last thing I
have to do to get that question mark
that unknown angle on its own is what I
do to both sides I should I should take
away theta the reason I know it's take
away - is because I got a plus there so
I want to undo that okay so if I take
away theta from that side I'll just be
left with under angle if I take away
from this side I get this 90 degrees
minus theta because I'm actually gonna
put that in there now that's 90 degrees
minus theta this is very important let's
just quickly have a think about like an
example of this okay and those of you
who had a look at what we did last night
we're doing this already let's pick
let's pick a feet up let's pick a few
okay so here's the same triangle okay
and what was the example I gave before
20 degrees for instance I got 20 degrees
yeah
so according to this what we've just
gone through here this other angle
should be 90 minus theta 90 minus 20
which is 7 70 degrees and you can add
adopt check write 20 plus seventy plus
90 sure enough it's a hundred eighty
just like you expect okay
there's something very important here
come back to to this diagram we've
already noted that sine theta equals
opposite I have onions
opposite fun news okay but now imagine
you're from the point of view of this
red angle now so I've changed position
I'm standing over here if I want to work
out cause of that angle up there cause
of this angle the red one what's close
be careful okay because now that we've
switched sides right yes it's this one
on this one right this one over this one
they put some letters on here let's call
this a and B and C I think that's what
we call it yesterday
okay so sine theta would be opposite on
hypotenuse in a be sorry go back to blue
here to be B on C right yes now when I
do this one cause of this angle it'll be
adjacent on hypotenuse it will also be B
on C because C now my opposite and my
adjacent have switched around because
I'm looking from the point of view of
this guy that's right that's exactly the
hypotenuse has always stuck there
opposite the right angle
he's always longest side and it's blue
the other one but adjacent and
hypotenuse depends where you're standing
right so so look at these these two guys
here these are really important okay and
if I that's what we were looking at last
night those if you did so here is this
guy and this guy which apparently are
the same and in fact this is why cause
is named what it is let's write this out
for you I'd love you to write this up to
side they don't equals because okay and
the example we gave down here was for
example sine of 20 degrees should be
equal to cos of so news I want you to go
back to yesterday's notes and we named
all of these but we notice there are
abbreviations right we said this is sine
they said this is cosine and I said the
car stood for something it's a little
preface there which means is anyone
remember can anyone see it means
compliment right two angles are
complements when they add up to 90
degrees like these two or like these two
or any other pair of angles you'll like
to end up tonight so for instance what
if I said this sign off I'll give you
that over sine of 30 degrees it should
be equal to cos of now what's the
complement of think it's 60 right cuz
again you can add these up right and
they'll be the same let me give you know
sine of 40 equals cos off now what's the
angle they're gonna add up to it'll be
50 100 40 plus 50 equals that's right
they add up to 90 so they're complements
and their complement and there and these
guys are complements
now we're going to do one more the one
Tom mentioned actually what if I made
this one over here 45 what's the
compliment of 45 also 45 huh okay now
you can get calculator out you can get
your cash and you can find out what all
of these numbers are it'll give you some
we don't looking decimal and then you
can check all of these on the right hand
side and they'll be the same okay yep
yep every single time okay now I'll just
start drawing this one because Tom
mentioned it before
what triangle would this look like it
would be either be isosceles yeah cuz
you got your right angle we talked with
you all in my name were triangles right
this would be 45 but you already told me
the complement of 45 is 45 you know base
angles equal so that means these guys
are equal right so for instance you
might have one one if you do Pythagoras
you'll find it that that's the square
root of two
so if you did sign 45 it be opposite 100
to the square root of 2 1 point for what
I did Pythagoras oh my head
and because I've seen this triangle a
thousand times so I know antique with
you ok cos 45 in the same way would be
it's a Jason and Jason it's also this
number you can check it out Zack 0.71
something ok ok
well done rule that off let's have a
look at a question and let's do it
together because all of this is going to
feed into that yeah let's get a missile
help yes it depends on what theories so
here's a whole bunch of example answer
so this is the big important thing here
yeah that's what I was trying to show it
well Y sine and cosine why is it what
does that have to do with anything right
like you need to know why things are
named what they are and this is why he's
a whole bunch of